hi martin are you there
i'm here yep can you hear me yes perfect
okay so martin is professor of
statistics and ecs at uc berkeley
so i think i don't need to enumerate the
long list of awards and titles
that martin has so i believe many of us
learned about high dimensional
statistics and probability
from martin's textbook and recently
martin begins to
think about studio theory in
reinforcement learning
all right can everyone see the screen
and hear me properly
yes okay great um so thanks so much to
the organizers mundy and
at all for the invitation to be here
putting together the workshop it
looks like a really great lineup of
speakers um and i'm excited to learn
um so today i want to talk a little bit
about um
a recent line of work on instance
dependent optimality
um that i've been doing with some
collaborators here at berkeley uh kulik
ashwin and fung and also my colleague
mike jordan
okay so the broad motivation for this
line of work is that we've seen
tremendous progress in
reinforcement learning uh particularly
over the past decade or
decade and a half both in the applied
and theoretical realms
um but i think it's fair to say that
there's still a lot of pretty big gaps
between theory and practice
many algorithms that we're using in
practice are behaving far better
than existing theory would suggest and
often they're working in settings where
current worst-case guarantees
say that they should not work that the
complexity would be completely
prohibitive
um even other algorithms we don't really
understand at all why they work
so the broad goal of the work that i'm
talking about today is
is trying to get theoretical guarantees
that align more closely with
what one sees in practice and i think
ultimately
trying to get theory that will be useful
to practitioners that can actually um
guide practice
so what is the issue with
um worst case and what motivates looking
at
what i'll call instance optimality in
this talk
um so in statistics there's a very
standard notion of
of what's called minimax theory it's
based on decision theory
where you're trying to estimate
something i'll call it theta hat
throughout the talk
to be concrete just imagine theta hat is
a value function
theta star is the true unknown value
function let's say
and you're measuring with some loss
function l how well your estimator is
doing
um you take an average over the samples
that you observe you get something
called the risk function
now the risk function of course varies
as a function of the true parameter here
on the x-axis
and the key question of course is how to
scalarize it how to give one number
that tells you how good the estimator
theta hat is
and there's different ways of doing this
the classical way is
to take the worst case over all
parameters and that would
excuse me pick off this problem here
with the red star that's the hardest
problem in this toy ensemble
and it would measure estimators on this
worst case risk
um but of course the concern here is
that that measure
is not sort of meaningful for this
problem here which is somehow a much
easier instance
so people propose various ways around
this if you have a
good prior over problem space then you
might compute a bayesian risk
but what i'd like to do today is is not
put a prior i'd like to actually
discuss how to get bounds that are
instance dependent so i'll get a bound
for a neighborhood around this easy
problem and i'll get a very different
bound
for a neighborhood around this hard
problem and that's what we mean by
instance dependent bounds
okay so that kind of question that i've
posed is is pretty general one can ask
that about any kind of
learning or estimation problem in rl um
today i want to focus on
really a very simple problem the most
classical at all
which is just policy evaluation in a
tabular mdp
now you might think well that's just so
simple it's boring
but you'll see that when you ask
questions about instance dependence
you start to get answers that are
non-trivial so even in such a simple
setting
this is an interesting notion to explore
okay so just reminder a tabular mdp has
let's say capital d
states i'll look at the discounted
setting we've got a discount factor
gamma
um we're fixing a policy trying to
evaluate the associated value function
and we know that it satisfies this
bellman equation so p
bold face p is the transition operator
unknown to us
and what we're given is we're given a
set of samples r i p i
these are random quantities that are
samples of the transition operator
and the reward function um in this talk
i'll talk mainly about the generative
model
um so r i p i are drawn from the
generative model
and we'd like to get estimates that are
accurate in an l infinity norm
why is that well because those are the
ones that are most useful for instance
in policy optimization in performing
incremental improvement
okay so standard procedures least
squares temporal differences and
sequential td zero least squares td is
just the batch plug-in
you use your samples to form an
empirical approximation
to the transition matrix and an
empirical approximation to the reward
vector
and you plug them in the bellman
equation and you solve
td0 again just moving quickly and assume
everyone knows this
is just linear stochastic approximation
for trying to solve
the batch problem it has a sequence of
step sizes
and typically going to zero and perform
stochastic updates
one minus the step size times the
previous thing
and then plus the stochastic td operator
here
okay so when you implement td in
practice
of course its behavior depends a lot on
what problem you apply it to
so here what am i showing i'm showing
the behavior of
td0 applied to a very simple policy
evaluation problem
three of them in fact and i'm plotting
number of iterations
versus the l infinity error
and um so what you're going to see is
the algorithm is consistent that of
course
is known from classical work back to the
80s
but what's interesting of course is that
it its behavior depends strongly
here i'm showing with respect to the
discount factor the green curve is
discount factor 0.8 up to the red
0.99 and what the point of sample
complexity is is to sort of figure out
at what rate do these curves shift
upwards as a function in this case of
gamma
so we measure sample complexity by
fixing some target accuracy
drawing a horizontal line here i'm
trying to get an
answer that's accurate to 10 to the
minus 2. looking at where the curve
intersects
and obviously it's shifting to the right
as gamma goes towards 1.
all right so what is known about these
algorithms from a global minimax point
of view
many things are known they've been very
well studied
what's known is that if you have niad
samples let's say from the generative
model
then the plug-in estimate will be
accurate in l-infinity
with a log d from the number of states
one over square root of n and then
the horizon dependence the effective
horizon is one over one minus gamma that
has a factor of 1.5 when you look at l
infinity norm
equivalently the sample complexity is
growing like
log d over epsilon squared one minus
gamma cubed
okay so that that's the worst case
complexity and what that means is that
these curves
are shifting to the right as a cubic
function of
the um effective horizon of the problem
they're shifting cubically in the worst
case that is
okay so when you do global minimax it's
always interesting to look
at the proof of the result and see what
is the hardest
problem there's not necessarily a unique
hardest problem but
um there is a problem that will achieve
the the minimax risk
um so here's the simple the simplest but
most difficult problem that we know of
and it's really a distillation of um
constructions that were due to azar at
all and lattimore and hutter from
2013-14 period
um it's the two-state mrp in state one
you have reward zero state two you have
reward one
and the interesting part of it is that p
the transition probability
well staying in state one um
is chosen to be 1 minus a function of 1
minus gamma
so it's a quantity that's converging to
1
as gamma converges to 1.
state 2 is absorbing with reward one
and essentially what goes on here is
that because state two is
um absorbing the optimal value function
is
one over one minus gamma that gives you
a factor of
one minus gamma squared to sample
complexity
and this choice of p which is quite
delicate
dependent on the effective horizon gives
you another factor
of the effective horizon
okay so that is a problem for which you
will observe this cubic
scaling but if you look at this problem
probably your first impression is it
looks pretty artificial it's very
delicately constructed
certainly if i constructed random policy
evaluation problems
they wouldn't have this kind of strange
structure that this one does
um so that's sort of telling us that
probably
the behavior of the algorithm on this
problem is not going to be
representative of its behavior elsewhere
so that's the motivation for instance
optimality
we sort of understand for many problems
the global minimax risk but we'd like to
understand how algorithms behave
and how their behavior varies with
respect to particular problem instances
um so that's what i'll talk about now so
how does one formalize this
um well this is something that has been
formalized in statistics
um in the asymptotic setting going back
to the work of le com
and more recently in non-asymptotic
settings that's actually what we're most
interested in this talk
non-asymptotic meaning for a finite
sample size
not letting the sample size go to
infinity
there's actually a fair bit of work
these days in non-parametric statistics
on
on that kind of question
okay so what are we going to study well
we know that in l infinity
the the error is going to zero at the
rate one over square root n so we're
going to rescale
the error by square root n that's
allowing us to expose the constant
that's in front of that term
now we can't just ask about for a fixed
problem
what the best estimator is because for a
fixed problem the best estimator just
ignores the data
and returns the true value function
so one has to do some kind of averaging
or worst case but
the key is we're going to do this over
very specially chosen local subsets here
and then to get minimax the minim means
that we take the
emphem over all possible estimators so
not just td
or not just lstd you can do whatever you
like with the data you observe
we'd like to understand what the
fundamental limits are
okay so it's it's really in this theory
it's the choice of this neighborhood
that is key this local neighborhood
in global minimax this is not a local
neighborhood it's the entire problem
space
but in local instance optimality we
choose this in particular ways in the le
comm theory what one does is
you define a neighborhood at scale s
that is shrinking at rate one over root
n
um and you ask that your algorithm
before performs well over
problems that belong to this very small
but shrinking neighborhood
um in this problem square root n is the
right rate to shrink the neighborhood
because we know that the risk is going
to zero at square root
the rate one over square root n
for non-asymptotic bounds we're going to
do something else we're going to take
just a worst case over
two-point families so for a given
problem
call it script j we're just going to
measure how well you do on j
and some other instance that we're going
to choose
that instance is is typically going to
be chosen quite close to j it's going to
be in a very small neighborhood of j
because it was very far away it would be
easy to tell them apart
all right so that's the notion of
instance optimality
what can we say for policy evaluation
okay so we're going to fix an instance
which is parametrized by a transition
matrix p
and a reward function r we're going to
have n
iid samples for this result
and we define what's known as the
optimal covariance matrix
so what is it it has the covariance of
your optimal value function under the
action of your sampling mechanism pi
is a random matrix sampled p is the
transition operator deterministic
it has the covariance of however you're
sampling your rewards
this could be zero if it's deterministic
but otherwise you have some
non-trivial covariance if you have a
stochastic reward mechanism
and then it has pre factors of identity
minus gamma p
inverse right so these of course are
doing the natural thing that you'd
expect that's measuring how
when i make errors at one particular um
iteration of the markov chain how do
those errors compound over time
via powers of the transition operator
okay so sort of obvious that this should
be the thing if you do a little
calculation
but here's what you can prove you can
prove asymptotically if you let n go to
infinity
and you look over a le com neighborhood
then the l infinity risk is equal to the
expectation of a gaussian
that's zero mean and has exactly this
covariance
okay so that's an asymptotic expression
because it's requiring that n
is large but it's exact
okay that is the the best that you can
do with any procedure
um whatsoever
that's relatively easy to prove just
using standard lecom techniques
um more challenging to prove is the
following non-asymptotic bound
um what this bound says is that once the
sample size n is big enough it has to be
bigger than
one minus gamma to the minus two
um that's a reasonable level because if
you have stochastic rewards
you can't actually get consistent
estimates um
unless you have n at least that large
and then what it says is if you look at
just the worst case in a two-point
neighborhood of your instance
your minimax risk is some constant a
half something like that
times the the maximal um should be the
square root of the maximal diagonal of
this quantity
okay so that's that's a bound that holds
for finite samples and again
for for any estimator
all right so now what becomes
interesting now we understand that this
object here is the fundamental quantity
and it becomes interesting to sort of
look at how it varies
over possible instances that we might be
looking at
um here's a slightly larger sandbox
um by the way i'm not obsessed with
two-state markov
decision processes or this particular
one
it's just that i like to have very
simple illustrations
that show the behavior of theory and
this is the simplest illustration that
we could work out
so it's essentially it's an extension of
the previous worst case
instance where now what we've done is
we've added
instead of the reward being one here
i've made it one minus gamma to some
power of lambda bigger than zero
if you put lambda equals zero that's the
previous worst case instance
but as lambda grows what happens is that
this reward shrinks
and it approaches this reward and so as
that happens the variance of the policy
evaluation problem shrinks the problem
becomes easier and easier as a function
of this gamma so what you can actually
proved
as a corollary of that previous result
is that
the worst case complexity over this
family as a function of gamma and
lambda looks like the effective horizon
to the power 1.5 but minus lambda
so if lambda is 0 that's the worst case
instance that's globally minimax
but as lambda increases the problem gets
much easier
okay so we're going to look at the
behavior of td on this
class of problems um
so what we'd like to understand is td
actually optimal
um somehow asking whether td is optimal
is a bit of a straw man it's it's sort
of obvious
if you look at stochastic approximation
theory from the 70s and 80s that it will
not be optimal
um the more natural question to ask is
td learning optimal when you combine it
with
polyacryl averaging and that's just a
simple but
ultimately quite useful scheme where you
run the ordinary td
updates that's generating this sequence
theta hat
and then you just average along the path
that's called polyjack rupert averaging
and why do you do this well you do this
because it allows you to run the base td
algorithm here
with a much more aggressive step size
for instance even constant step sizes
are are okay so this algorithm
with a constant step size is going to
have very high variance it's going to be
very noisy but it's going to move very
quickly
and then the averaging is obviously a
form of variance reduction
and it was the inside of rupert and then
poliak to actually prove things
about these kinds of schemes
so we can ask is td0 with pr averaging
an instance optimal algorithm
um that's a bit of a trick question
because
if you just do the sort of classical
kind of asymptotic scaling where the
sample size goes to infinity
it's not hard to show that it is
asymptotically instance optimal
but one thing we've learned from high
dimensional statistics is that
asymptotics can be very misleading
um so in high dimensional statistics we
do very different things we do things
like this
we um take a sequence of sample sizes
that
is going to z to infinity but it's going
to infinity only because
some other problem parameter for
instance here the discount parameter
gamma is going to one so
what i'm doing is looking at sequences
of problems that are indexed by the
complexity
as the complexity grows i'm giving you
more samples
i'm recognizing that it's a harder
problem i will give you more samples but
still a finite number of samples for any
problem and i'm actually giving you
enough samples that
in terms of global minimax you for any
problem
you should be able to obtain constant
error with this many samples
now what am i doing i'm actually doing a
simulation for a problem that's easy
i'm simulating for lambda is 1.5
in this sandbox here so lambda is 1.5
and what that means is the minimax risk
is actually constant as a function of
the effective verizon
and because i'm giving you square root n
i'm giving you n
samples that scales with the effective
horizon then actually the lower bound
which is in green
these problems are getting easier as a
function of gamma
and that's what the lower bound tells us
that you're getting lower and lower
error so at the highest choice of gamma
you see roughly a factor of four
difference this is an order of magnitude
in terms of log error between
these are tdpr curves with either a
constant step size or a polynomial step
size
okay so this tells you that not all
asymptotically optimal algorithms are
equal all right all of these algorithms
are asymptotically optimal
but the black algorithm which i'll tell
you about is clearly much better than td
pr averaging in this particular regime
all right so that's interesting to learn
that td and pr averaging is not
an instance optimal algorithm in finite
samples
all right so how does one get an
instance optimal algorithm
um the answer or what you would try
is actually pretty straightforward it's
the analysis that turns out to be rather
delicate in our work
um as i mentioned before pr averaging is
one form of variance reduction
but we know many kinds of variance
reduction in
stochastic approximation schemes and
so-called direct variance reduction
techniques are very well known in
stochastic optimization
where they first appeared about 10 years
ago and
they've been used increasingly in
reinforcement learning um
in the past few years for problems both
for td and for
cue learning for instance the paper by
sidford at all
i won't go into detail just because i
don't have time
but just high level what are these
algorithms doing
um t hat is my short form for
the random td
operator based on a particular sample i
um what these algorithms are doing is at
every epoch
often they're epic based they're
maintaining a re-centering point that's
computed
and they're taking the td update and
they're
re-centering it by subtracting the td
update applied to the
the theta bar the recentering point and
then adding back in a term
t twiddle is an unbiased approximation
to the full
bellman update the reason they're doing
this
is to reduce variance you can do some
calculations to see that the variance
of this update shrinks as theta
and theta bar approach the truth theta
star
okay so what we can show so again this
idea is not new but the analysis
i believe is new here is that
if you use a suitable choice of the step
sizes and the epochs
um there's some details here that i'm
skipping over but they're they're all in
the paper that's cited there
then if you run this very introduced
form of policy evaluation
using a total of n samples um
what you'll get is you will get an
estimate that an l infinity norm is
less than or equal to a constant plus
something that's smaller order than
this quantity here and this quantity has
the terms that you expect it has log d
over square root n and it has the
diagonal should actually be a square
root of this diagonal
my apologies has the square root of the
diagonal of the
um optimal asymptotic covariance matrix
okay so this is saying that this is an
instance optimal procedure
um up to some constants possibly log
factors that we don't have full control
over what sort of key is that it's
depending exactly on this
optimal covariance that's identified
in the lower bounds excuse me
what's capital d capital d is the number
of states
in the tabular mrp so you get a log d
from the union bound
yeah any other questions
um so something we don't know how to fix
is that
this requires the sample size to be
larger than log d that's fine
but one minus gamma to the cube um
you'd like to reduce that to 1 minus
gamma squared that's what we see in the
lower bound
but currently we don't know how to do
that
okay so that's the theorem and you can
see from
our our simulations that it is indeed
matching the lower bound so these
diamonds here are showing you the
behavior of the variance reduced policy
evaluation algorithm
and computing a slope this slope will be
minus 1.5
and that's exactly what the minimax
theory the instance-dependent minimax
theory
suggests so we've proved
a general result but just in simulations
here's another instance
where again forms of td and pr are
very clearly sub-optimal and this is
achieving
this kind of instance dependent lower
bound for these easier problems
okay so let me just start to wrap up so
up to now i've been talking about
um we've identified
the sort of correct functional to look
at when we study instance dependence and
policy evaluation
um i motivated the talk by saying that
we were interested in
um providing bounds that are useful in
practice
that's actually a deficiency of what
i've discussed so far this optimal
covariance depends on things that are
not known
um for a practitioner you'd like things
a bound that depends only on known
quantities
um we don't yet know how to do that for
td zero i'm pretty sure you can do it by
studying the um
sequence of iterates but um for the
plug-in quantity for lstd
we we do have a bound that depends
purely on
known quantities it depends on the
empirical transition matrix
and it depends on the empirical standard
standard deviation
of the bellman update um this is a bound
where
the rewards are um not stochastic so
there's there's no terms for that in the
way i've stated it here
okay so this is different right this is
a bound that is actually useful to the
practitioner
because everything that's bound can be
evaluated there's an explicit not
unreasonable choice of the constant c
and this is something that purely based
on your batch of data you can evaluate
in the interest of full disclosure
there's a slight deficiency that this
quantity
is not always matching this quantity
essentially we have a square root in the
wrong place that we'd like to
fix so there's interesting questions
here
roughly speaking what you'd like to do
is replace p by p
hat and replace covariance by covariance
hat
and you'd like to prove things based on
on the sample dependent version
so that's that's something where we have
partial results but it's not complete
all right so just to wrap up um
this talk was sort of motivated by it by
a more general question which
i think is interesting which is that of
sort of closing gaps between worst-case
theory and
algorithms in practice um what we did is
derived lower bounds
in both asymptotic and finite sample
settings
for policy evaluation interestingly td
learning even with policy
with polar group averaging this is not
instance optimal in finite samples it is
asymptotically
optimal just using known results due to
poliak and yuditsky but
when you actually study it more
carefully in this kind of high
dimensional statistics scaling
we see suboptimalities um variance
reduced pe
fixes those sub-optimalities
now i think there's maybe more open
questions
raised by this work than answered um
obviously we've studied only the
generative setting we'd like to do
things in markov settings
that brings in mixing times it's not
clear whether one
should do things in l infinity perhaps
we should be doing things in in an l2
mu norm where mu is the stationary
measure
um we can say something about a linear
function approximation where that's how
lstd is
is actually used but again thinking
about function approximation
more generally um requires some new
things
the the lower bounds will hold more
generally but
the variance reduction or analysis of it
actually uses
certain details that are quite specific
to policy evaluation
um but i guess in general i'm quite
excited about understanding instance
optimality in
in much more general settings i sort of
view this as
an initial set of steps in that
direction
so a couple of pre-prints um papers and
pre-prints for those of you interested
and um
happy to take any questions thanks
okay thank you martin so let's open up
the discussions
so anyone who has a question i think you
can either ask in the q a
chat box or you can just unmute yourself
uh you shang are you there i thought you
want to add something
oh yeah yeah um yeah thanks for the
great talk um
i have many questions but i wanted to
first ask the question to shai
uh um so um
well you're talking you start a very
interesting problem
of the behavior policy and target policy
having different
um like information uh in in
specifically the the
behavior policy might depend on like the
unknown state but in the target policy
wanted to um
like evaluate a palm dp policy right so
so i if you understand correctly that's
the setting
um but um i i'm i'm wondering like
whether
the the problem of people's behavior
policy and the targeting policy are palm
dp policies with the same information
a kind of a more reasonable setting
because you can you can either observe
um the state or observe certain
information of the state and that should
be shared among policies
if you want to do this more generally
there's a two by two table of
settings according to the partial full
observable
observability of the two policies and in
the simplest case when they share the
same information like perhaps
um the the existing literature on ope
would work and there's
no confounding issues like is that a
right comment i just wanted to hear what
you think about this problem
so the comment is uh is correct uh um i
mean
the the issue though is that uh at least
in applications uh
we have a big study and some medical
application that
i'm i didn't uh say anything about uh um
this is really not the case uh the the
doctors
when they see actually see the patients
and feel the the patient's pulse
and look at their uh if they smile or or
not and
they know uh they know a lot more so
they do make decisions
we cannot explain uh by uh
is well motivated problem and thanks
um i have another question to you to
marty um
um so uh so i'm wondering whether it's
just a
simple uh mle plugin right so so you
estimate the
mdp parameters and plug-in um like that
should uh
have like instance optimality right i
think monday is going to be talking
about that later this afternoon
um but but are there um like the
specific advantages
of using the variance reduced td
over the standard like plugging estimate
well yeah so the plug-in estimate of
course is not stochastic approximation
so it doesn't
suffer from some of these problems that
an online algorithm does
um to my knowledge
i'm pretty sure the plug-in is instance
optimal
um but as i mentioned my results with
ashwin
don't actually show full instance
optimality i think as far as i know
that's open
but i think in practice well this
problem is so toy that it doesn't really
matter but
moving to more realistic problems we
want to do online procedures
so somehow understanding optimal online
procedures i i think is quite
interesting
all right thanks
um okay so i'll ask a question on behalf
of emma because she's
she has to go for a meeting so so this
is uh too shy
so so basically when we have compounding
factors and partial observabilities
is like batch rl could be zero
intractable right
and then to get around of this we need
some sort of decoupling
so what do you think uh do things like
shall we just try to
get this kind of the covenant assumption
from domain experts
or how do we can we try to evaluate
assumptions directly from data
i mean so that's a good question in
principle you could uh
try to do it from data but you'll need a
heck of a lot of uh data
uh to evaluate uh um conditional
independence so
so uh domain expert is a good way to
start but i think uh from a theory
perspective a really interesting
question is what if you we can measure
the level of decoupledness and uh um
that there has been works in the in the
ci literature about
about that and uh but still we haven't
been able to
uh uh to wrap our heads around it
because testing independence requires a
lot of data right
exactly yeah so it's hard to draw a line
between what's known what's not known
right unless you make some pretty pretty
uh
outrageous assumptions uh on the shape
of the
distribution then then i agree with you
yeah thank you thank you shai and
also i have a question for yandong so
uh you know i'm still there yeah i'm
still here okay
so there's a question in the chat about
how do you define the optimal site
of the agent do you want to repeat the
definition
of sight oh yeah so i think i already
replied that in uh threats uh but i'm
going to talk about that so i think this
is actually related to the series so
there's
the serum one in the first part of the
slides basically there's a constant c
and d here so we depend on like if the
side is larger
uh then this c and d will become also
like a
i mean for example like a larger right
so in that case the bond will be
stronger so that's basically like a
trade-off i mean if
you a if one agent only see like a very
small
local uh region and a lot very small
like
local uh states number of states from
other agents nearby then
that bond will be looser so that's
basically a trade-off
and also there's one thing i didn't i
think i might have missed
so how did you get around with this
exponential complexity
was there any assumption about how how
the agent sort of like
decomposed the state space naturally
yeah so basically the assumption here is
uh
each agent once they have their own
rewards they will go to basically go
there
and then i you basically pick the reward
that you get that's the best thing you
can do
right so for example you basically say
that uh
for each of the agent you you have to
basically pick example
the closest rewards if you're picking
like a very far away rewards
then because of this count factor this
gun factor will prevent you from doing
that
because this is actually not optimal
because of this
kind of property you can say okay maybe
each agent just pick
objects that is nearby or finish the
task that is closer to it
so this actually enabled the disbound so
that's the reason
so so there's some notion of locality
that
yes exactly i mean that how much
how how many steps you're going from one
position to another position
right and this locality basically enable
this kind of composition great that
makes sense
okay yeah so so i also have a question
for martin so martin so
you explained so why do we need to care
about this localized min max
risk right so um i think
so we need a notion of neighborhood of
instances right
so that particular notion of
neighborhood
is that important here for example like
in your result
so can we just pick an arbitrary norm to
define the neighborhood
or would that change the rate um
so in the la com theory because you're
taking limits and the neighborhood is
going to zero
the choice of the norm is is actually
irrelevant all that matters is that
it goes to zero at sort of the right
rate in this case it's a parametric
problem so one over square root n
um in the other
non-asymptotic bound we proved the
neighborhood is just two point so
there's no sort of
norm um the the worst case two-point
problem obviously involves
you the problem you're studying and a
problem very close to it
because it's not hard to give the
algorithm a problem very far away
because it can just test and figure out
which problem it's looking at
um so my understanding is like that
there will be some issue if we consider
non-asymptotic bonds right if we only
care about asymptotic error bonds
it sort of doesn't really change much in
the in the mean result
yeah i think one message from my talk is
that there are a lot of algorithms for
instance
you know arguably td plus pr is a very
simple algorithm it's it's very easy to
implement pr averaging
it is asymptotically optimal um but as
you can see
it in finite samples it's dominated by
orders of magnitude by
another algorithm um to be fair the the
form of
variance reduction that we analyze these
epoch-based algorithms
um if you've ever implemented them
they're a pain in the ass that this
is sort of honesty in application
be much better to be able to prove
something about the more online versions
of variance reduction that people know
in stochastic optimization i think those
are are much better
so but you know that plot i showed you
with you know several orders of
magnitude difference is telling you that
these things matter um we're sort of
actually looking at higher order terms
really
but higher order terms matter with
finite samples can matter with finite
samples
and also the the finite sample size
condition
about this this conditional end is not
entirely iron out
right it's not entirely what it's not
entirely iron out so it was we don't
it's not
tight yet right no it's not tight we our
analysis of variance reduction needs
a larger sample size than the lower
bound would suggest
so right right yeah yeah we don't know
how to do that
yeah thank you um so do we have any
brutal questions let me look at
the q a chat box or does anyone want to
ask questions like sure i guess i guess
um
martin um beautiful work i'm looking
forward to following up
um i i yeah one question i did have
throughout was
how complex it is to run these things
and i guess i guess that's
somehow factored in on your bounds like
how just the overhead and running these
algorithms
and the other comment i want to make is
this class of problems you're looking at
the only thing that creates that one
over one minus gamma
difficulty is that the value function
has a constant in it
that grows like one of one minus gamma
so if you subtract off a constant
it suddenly becomes much more tame
maybe maybe you could comment on that i
mean it's the only one-dimensional
problem that's causing the trouble um
yeah no i completely agree just to be
clear i'm i'm not that interested in the
one minus gamma scaling alone
i just chose it because it's it's a sort
of a one-dimensional way to show very
big differences
in the instance um dependence
at some level i think studying like if
you look at those two toy instances i
gave
they're very artificial like as you
pointed out you have an absorbing state
with sort of
a value function that's growing at the
worst possible rate
and then the problems are sort of
quasi-deterministic
most other problems are much much much
easier than this
so that's sort of a message i think
that's useful is that the worst case
theory is is very conservative in this
case
you know i just but i love this toy i
wonder how
much i'll be able to play with it like
control verits with such a letdown
because the
theory is so beautiful and yet it's it's
often the overhead of applying them
is so massive that you don't get to use
them and so do you have faith that these
will actually be things that will be
you could actually plug in and get huge
benefits
the variance reduction to be clear about
what's unpleasant it's it's not
more expensive by any means what's
unpleasant is that it has parameters it
has epochs
and epochs have lengths and it has step
sizes within epochs and there's sort of
a lot going on like the beauty of td
plus pr is you just throw in
a constant step size and you average it
it's just plug and play
you know a monkey could implement that
algorithm
that's not true for these epics in the
linear case the non-linear algorithms
it's
it's pretty horrible as well if you up
here okay yeah true so yeah
my case that i talked about today is
very special because of linearity but um
yeah but but as i said there are other
forms of this variance reduction in
stochastic optimization that
are much more amenable to implementation
my suspicion is one can
adapt this kind of analysis to the more
general fixed point setting in
stochastic approximation
i think that's quite interesting to
think about yeah
okay but thanks for your question sean i
appreciate it sure
yeah uh any more question
okay we shall take a small break
and we'll be back here in 15 minutes
thank all the speakers again for the
beautiful talks
thank you thanks for cheering mandi
thanks everyone
thanks everyone thank you